imaginez ce que ça peut représenter
conduire pour la toute première fois
pendant l'hiver sur la glace mais en
plus vous avez un loup au chargement à
trani mais ça c'est le défi que relève
des camionneurs américains qui sont
venus travailler au canada il ya une
telle pénurie en fait de camionneurs au
canada que des compagnies de transport
recommencera tenant se tourner vers de
la main d'oeuvre étrangère geneviève
marche aussi bien emmitouflés rosetta
thompson vérifie son moteur il fait
moins 25 degrés tout un écart avec la
jamaïque son pays d'origine où elle a
travaillé dans l'industrie durant sept
ans jusqu'au jour où est né le rêve de
conduire sur des routes de glace c'est
la télé réalité américaine sur l'
aventure des conducteurs nordiques qui
l'attiré au canada elle travaille avec
cinq autres caribéen pour une compagnie
de transport de winnipeg avec la
croissance de l'industrie du transport
et le vieillissement des routiers
canadien il y à une importante pénurie
de camionneurs quand les camionneurs
manque les salaires augmentent et la
facture est refilée aux consommateurs et
la pénurie pourrait s'accentuer
davantage selon l'alliance canadienne du
camionnage
il manquera jusqu'à 25000 camionneurs
d'ici 2020 voilà pourquoi l'industrie se
mobilisent et multiplie les efforts de
recrutement chez horizon transports il
faudra remplacer plusieurs conducteurs
d'ici cinq ans mêlant bonche à
l'étranger comporte trop de risques
et du coup des lois très différent des
règles très différentes et route très
différente au climat très différents
la semaine de travail est plus longue et
il y a les dangers liés à l'hiver
les camionneurs étrangers reçoivent
d'ailleurs deux semaines de formation
and run est heureux dans son pays le
taux de chômage atteint 16%
ici il peut conduire le jour son
employeur tournera sous peu en jamaïque
pour recruter six autres conducteurs ici
geneviève marché synovate au canada
winnipeg